welcome to this video from a pro Mateo
and primito I don't know 77 from
Argentina so some of Kings Indian or
entire gruenfelder let's go with the
Kings Indian I could play the Petrosian
system for once not a regular feature of
my repertoire but why not this is
actually how does this actually work I
think something like this the castling
early on him yeah probably Queenie aids
I have a vague memory that King h1 is a
move somewhere around here belief and
I'm not quite sure why if they go at
five can I not just play either okay
that he do he's doing for this okay now
g5g five and each floor was threatening
to win the peace and here is here this
is a funny situation I think they quite
often allow the Bishop to e3 but i'm
going to play Bishop of two and that
looks more harmonious to me just Quincy
to now maybe looks normal
I'd like to go before you of course a
groupie wanted before I said something
wrong with that just asking this night
if it is really well placed
that looks fairly normal for this
opening each form so is he going for age
38 r EG three and 95 stuff like that
yeah that's possible but can I do
something about it I can it can maybe
take on f5 is this something that why
players quite often doing this in this
kind of opening but a tree g3 is this I
don't really see why this is so
dangerous I know maybe I should have
played some kind of prophylactic move ok
this is what he wanted to do I didn't
really didn't really understand that
correctly so if i go on the side now I
Queen g5 as a move that he wants to play
and then my night is a ticket hmm okay
so maybe I should actually try to get a
square for the night like this maybe I
don't really believe you can can grab
that pawn on c5 that looks very
dangerous like indeed a tech d takes be
takes Knight takes Knight c5 that looks
really dangerous
I just want to make sure that if he goes
Queen g5 that I'm having night see for
this was the main reason for c5
everything taking this will be will be
dangerous for him now of course he takes
that maybe he has to wear maybe he has
to that that's definitely possibility
that he had no choice but this looks
interesting now my main idea is to go d6
here d 6 pawn takes 95 and this is
getting ugly so even here d 6 is an
interesting idea what is he doing that I
don't get it can you even think with the
Queen okay then I'm going and get me
going with this not spending any more
time so i can take here and even Queen
takes e4 is a move + 95 it's both
interesting 25 though I would like to
have Knight takes e4 in that case
okay I'm taking with this I'm unsure
that's really kind of interesting this
position v 7s it's under fire and I'm
threatening 95 things very active plus
g6 hangs I'm not sure if I'm better or
anything but it feels interesting very
active position okay if you overlook
moves like that you know that something
is off in you again g6 is hanging though
so I'm taking this I should have seen
the move well and then I mean not sure
what this is if I'm will see or anything
but I should see it and then decide if i
do something about it or not ok anyway
96 here on what's happening now let's
look at six
okay now I Bishop c6 puzzle strong rules
what is this guy here 444 person pretty
old account behind my little plate him
though Queen g64 age three or something
I don't know I'm going here could have
taken c5 maybe but let's centralized a
little bit I just got rooked g8 this is
pretty strong will gave to us what I
have to do but not very attractive I
played this am didn't play that well I
feel that this breakthrough should be
callable care at least
and it probably has some kind of b5 move
okay that is threatening a lot on age 3
on e4 and everything Wow don't have a
museum now was nicely played okay i have
half no move 94 in particular where's
the bun here right resins okay I'm
really curious I don't think this is bad
no of course I'm straight winning here
with Bishop a 6 ok I couldn't really
believe that he can just allow this year
like that but I had the entirely wrong
idea of course I can just take a 6 how
stupid can you be this this and like a
black isn't in bad shape yeah something
like I could be five I mean this is this
is just up for the taking I'd was still
it's so kind of messy but yeah that's of
course what I have to do this that's
also very good actually d 6 and now 95
instead of the capture so this first
queen g5
no then I have 96 the engine gives this
at the best line but what is also in
good shape you everything's hanging now
III this is the entrance main lodge with
some with an advantage that's still kind
of messy yeah this is what I have to do
I mean this I really never thought about
Bishop c6e in this position but it is
very strong of course if I get the b7
porn I'm in really nice shape all the
light squares I'm dominating and here
Jack this is now very nice he I'm
basically lost already I don't really
see any anything here Quinn there's
noise playing nicely on the attacker g8
for the attack takes Teague snatch 570
executed this very nice day after I let
him let him do it c5 I guess he has to
do something else but not a huge fan of
this position may be Queen g5 and matts
you form
yeah those positions are always always
tricky and even though first glance you
think that black is busted but he's got
he's got pieces on the other King I mean
this doesn't look like it can be any
good yeah like this 95 and what is this
night only six doing anyway but he's got
plenty of pieces and you cannot we
cannot really trust the computer here
it's a well known that in those Kings
Indian type of position the computer
tends to be M overconfident about white
wines chance because the attack that
black hair sometimes has this kind of
slow creeping quality it will ultimately
hit but it just takes a while at times
yeah so that what was my chance after
you take in here and to take a six and
takes you five okay well thanks for
watching